The landscape of software development
has drastically changed over the last
10, 20 years, and
will continue to do so.
I think the scariest phrase in
the English language is we've
always done it that way.
With advances in hardware and
software, the pace of innovation
has only accelerated.
Old methodologies
simply can't keep pace.
Instead of shipping one major version
every couple of years, software
companies are continuously updating
services that are offered online.
When was the last time you got
software delivered via CD?
People just expect new features and
fixes to happen quickly without
disruption to their daily lives.
Common roadblocks like getting
access to infrastructure have
pretty much been eliminated.
Virtualization has changed the game for
operational teams.
Now you can create
servers in minutes and
harness the full power of
those physical resources.
Development teams have more opportunity
to create templates, clone, snapshot,
roll back, and
destroy whole environments.
There's also online services like AWS or
Digital Ocean,
where you can go and test your code.
Today, people don't have a lot of
sympathy in our on demand society.
If your site doesn't work or your app is
buggy, people have multiple ways to let
you know, which leads to
tarnishing your brand's image.
This puts extreme pressure on
developers and operations but
also product managers and
business people.
How do you manage everything
at this new pace?
How do you change old habits and
organizational structures and
processes to adapt?
A development process with a long detail
design phase, and a planning phase, and
then another long implementation phase
is slow, inefficient and error-prone.
To top it off, organizational silos that
prevent communication leads to stale
information, misconceptions, and
further slows down the process.
What arose from the ashes
of past mistakes?
Agile development was born.
Constant feedback with an iterative
approach allows to find problems quickly
for both developers,
and operations teams.
But Agile covers just the first
part of the application life cycle,
which is development.
Another part of the puzzle comes from
using Agile and Lean approaches,
incorporating operations.
With people still working in
their Silos, bottlenecks remain.
Breaking down the silos,
allow collaboration through
all stages of the development.
And this brings us to
the definition of Devops.